are there more doors or wheels in the  world that's the big one that went viral  recently oh for real yeah you got two  wheels on the car but usually two or  four doors you also got little things  like the gas tank door but then you got  two oh  oh  god  i love when you read like i bet this kid  one time that i go uh if the if the  seahawks win i'll give you 200 but if  the rams when i get to cut you your hair  and he didn't think it through he  thought i wanted to cut his hair he was  10 years old and i [ __ ] this kid's  head up the first thing i did i cut his  bangs like simple jack and he looked at  me and he goes does it look cool  no i'm [ __ ] you up so that's what you  got that's why you got to do the math  that's how you get to the bathroom i'm  going i'm going wheels